[Musique]
marquise
marquise marquise si mon visage à
quelques trait un peu vieux
souvenez-vous qu'à mon âge vous ne
vaudrez guère mieux marquise si mon
visage a quelques trait un peu vieux
souvenez-vous comm mon âge vous ne
vaudraz guerre mieux ah le temps aux
plus belles choses se plaît à faire un
affront il sera fané Vose comme il a
ridé mon front le temps aux plus belles
choses se plaît à faire d'affront il
sera fané vos roses comme il a ridé mon
front le même cours des planètes règle
nos jours et nos nuits on m'a vu ce que
vous êtes vous serez ce que je suis le
même cours des planètes règle nos jours
et nos nuits on m'a vu ce que vous êtes
vous serez ce que je
suis peut-être que je serai vieille
répond marquise
cependant j'ai 26 ans mon vieux cor
jille et je t'en mer en
attendant j'ai 26 ans mon vieux
corneil et je t'emmerde en
[Musique]
attendant